[Music]
do you do that's all I really want
I know but I told you to not say nothing
until I [ __ ] introduce you dude he's
looking five four three two when he does
a [ __ ] thing dude
all right all right hey man look at me
steel you know him good huh yeah you
don't get it all right we'll get into it
you know I know I know what you're
saying you go ahead
5 4 3 2 1 2 3 4 5 4 3 2 1 2 3 welcome to
you do the thing welcome to our that's
fine
Jesus Jesus loves everyone in this room
and the Lord is in this room right now I
can feel it his energy and his arm even
the Lord his energy and we're all
connected by a a man bro hey [ __ ] I
told you not to talk and to I introduced
EULA sorry that's okay he's looking at
me yeah he is welcome to another edition
of the tiger Valley and that's what it
is and I don't like I see you know it
yeah and the thing is is that um you
know I tell the guests to do certain
things like just the [ __ ] up until
introduced um and they say things but
it's fine
because the thing is is that I want to
let everyone in this room know that I'm
still the captain of the ship and I'm
still your leader and you do as I say
you hear me white boy yeah bro dan and I
we got that beautiful girl right here so
I get up I go we got [ __ ] kalila we
got with Gilbert yep he's my sidekick
yeah burrito yeah you know Jason
Priestley a fan and you see it a little
yeah Jason Priestley ifs I am man and we
got huge hard-on together damn no co
[ __ ] bomb bro em talk dude thank you
for having me today
holy you said yeah it's a lot it smells
a lot more virile in here than I don't
what would it mean just more it smells
like there's more kind of hidden animals
in
and I think that I have them as pets or
other things I don't know yeah I think
you
I can imagine you've been through a lot
with different animals but I uh I'm
happy to be your man appreciate you
having me yeah I love animals and I love
you I've always loved you man I don't
know when I met you when did I meet you
hmm turned to how big you were whenever
we met probably same size so probably
maybe six years I was wrong in a long
time
you know me but when I met you our well
Thomas this white dude right here is he
funny my son go up man dang you sounds
very I don't know the Latin Kings Nell
Irvin okay bro bro just you got to be
okay
this [ __ ] is he funny was right
urban ball yeah
unstable [ __ ] dude yeah by killing that
guy Hawaiian Ohana me [ __ ] you went up
there dude he's [ __ ] got weird [ __ ]
bro Oishi his point of view and [ __ ]
about like what you saw mushy pigeon
Ares is about all I'm talking about it's
uncle and chimes I'm not all kinds of
[ __ ] do and I was like dude he's one of
us bro yeah and I saw him another time
do him and I did some jerk me off by a
dumpster yeah and I did you I did do
that excuse me what we work together we
work together where I had a jerk co-op
oh I didn't literally jerk him off at a
dumpster dude you do what I do in the
hotel room fine for now ah but it was
mine are we really I think we could but
you know what I'm saying yeah we really
did it yeah yeah I don't have any I
hardly have any feelings left in my
penis anyway I feel like at this age to
be honest
really and I'm not trying to be weirding
way because of a lot of masturbation or
you you get a lot of girls I think it's
a mix of everything man you know I've
been with some decent lemon and some
just troubled women and some undervalued
women all right yeah and you still you
still hook up with the ugly ones or what
no these days I mean you know I try to
find
and that you know a little bit of beauty
and everybody but sometimes you got to
really get in there to see it yeah what
do you mean I'm like right I know what
you're saying what you're saying is to
me this it's like you're okay you need
Agron line whatever yeah and their face
is fine legit right and then their body
is legit right then you get them naked
and then something legit is that what
you're saying yeah the foundation is
weak all right whatever I always said
you can't build a house back on accept
and core what was built on sand Angkor
Wat and Komodo
what okay oh yeah handle this guy right
here I know right here man okay
seriously from [ __ ] Thailand right
man yeah Razia yeah so love that guy
look like but you you don't [ __ ]
somebody we look out be real run
honestly know how I'm gonna see him I
think that you know he probably grew up
in a place and like a lot of chimes and
stuff yeah and a lot of cartons on rugs
on the wall yeah yeah yeah yeah ceiling
on the flooring yeah I know what you're
saying though is a mix match a lot of
places they put rugs on the wall instead
of the floor what is the kitchen look
like here the kitchen a lot of utensils
yes
so yes yeah one giant work one giant
chillin right yeah yeah a couple of
older Sammy's that look either that
could be men or women how do mine out of
my parents talk they don't talk anymore
yeah lookers do [ __ ] Co yeah I've got
to read all kinds of systems through the
eyes hombro yeah but there's a lot of
love and there but the lows all it's a
lot of loves historical so it's already
been built in you're not getting like a
lot of it these days it's just kind of
no yeah but it's really no no you feel
it yeah yeah I when I first met you dude
I didn't trust you yeah because you came
in there like a [ __ ] yellow butterfly
you've been dipping in zipping it out
what is it zip it into the a little you
laughs hey buddy
yeah yeah yeah with the ginger maggot
it's somebody that uh I'm hot somebody
my kindred town some sick ginger bro and
I've been on that for like two days
what you mean like like real ginger the
root yeah good animal from Hawaii
I wouldn't say Hawaii I am I am nobody
you know like somewhere closer than we
came into town are you being real you
came out of town
this guy with an actual rule ginger root
stuff McGee Canyon to close your eyes I
think my land did you make a juice out
of it at what you do
some some you eat if you get like real
in the inside part you eat it you juice
some of it you can cut it up and put it
in a eggs but it's just wrong Bo yeah
make your neck bro bro yeah in the rest
in the room
I love injured myself dude yeah the
other aid they used to go there was a
sign that said we only have Hawaiian
ginger and that for some reason just
because they put the sign up made it
seem even more potent yeah like you're
right if they hadn't put other like all
this is regular ginger yeah but they do
it was like a warning we only have
Hawaiian ginger yeah which scared the
[ __ ] out of us we drank it anyway you
know that's a game maker right there
ginger boy if you had to pick one spice
it's a real game a cup thank you what do
you mean by that man just you get enough
ginger in you man you don't even see
gender really yeah yeah maybe we'll talk
ahead yeah you'll [ __ ] a damn breeze
Charlie you're trying to [ __ ] a breeze
pastor yeah let me let me ask you
something man
you'll [ __ ] anything I feel stick around
your body yeah be a strong breeze a mist
yo yo do you weird guy huh yeah you know
what I thought you were unique Bobby was
when you got when you have a each other
talk about on stage when you said you
got molested you know yeah yeah because
I dealt with the mentally handicapped we
have a buncha mentally handicapped boss
when I was growing up and they were wild
what do you want Lou said this one man
was a farmer I guess mostly livestock so
yeah you know living crops yeah yeah
yeah and he uh he had a couple of mental
sons and they call them enols or kids
somebody hism that's when they yeah had
autism but they didn't want to make it
fancy autism so it's so French really
right right
so you just had addict ISM yeah you know
ISM and he had a couple [ __ ] sons
and I don't mean to say if anybody is
[ __ ] I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about these other [ __ ]
people that I knew when I was going and
he he had two [ __ ] sons that would
always be on horseback and so they were
yeah because they were live soccer yeah
yeah and then all wrote a lot of songs a
livestock he's too busy trying to so
what do they do to you anybody anything
no well they had one of them eventually
got injured I guess he got injured
somehow and then they got him a bicycle
that had a one of those you know mothers
you have the bicycle with that baby seal
on the back yeah yeah yeah with that
small baby seat like now they put you in
like this covered Conestoga wagon and
like you're like there's like roll bars
and stuff like I remember back in the
day used to like the kid would just be
like our you have to be active in the
back yeah regularly still like that yeah
like not even in the mother sites like
yeah yeah let's look back to here dunno
I was in Thailand just real quick I saw
a dude on a moped right he was wearing
this [ __ ] motorcycle helmet oh we had
a baby on his shoulder baby had no
helmet beautiful you might as well just
take the helmet officer and just tie
your baby to your head yeah use the baby
as a helmet right I mean yeah doesn't
bate practice right alright we don't put
a helmet on a baby yeah is a risky right
and then one of these guys got up was
mentally challenging he got a bicycle
eventually and they gave him they the
bike had a like a child mother's baby
seat on the back and I had never met
anybody that was gay they didn't have a
lot of gay people in our area and if
they did we didn't know about it till
we're older where did you grow up in
Louisiana and they didn't come by and
also you know when you grow up in like a
rural area like nobody really cares if
somebody's gay it's not like they're
running around like they don't have a
gay pride parade you know there's only
two gay dudes if they meet up in the
street they're probably just going to
[ __ ] a little yeah yeah they're not
going to put together a whole
parade for everybody Rui Rui right so um
if I people said that this man was a
homosexual yeah and they didn't have uh
and everybody's like wow and they said
that they said he had a husband like a
little husband that left him that you
should sit in that back seat ha ha ha
so there was always like a ton of not
remorse really I don't know what the
feeling is but when you saw this man go
by you're like aw it's so sad that his
little fun Mona its remorse yeah it's
for more CAS and it was just sad you
know cuz you're like oh this guy's a
little husband had left him and so I
believe everything you're saying because
we watched a documentary called mommy
dead and dearest you and everyone's from
Louisiana but like in the Bayou remember
how they yeah they we talked yeah yeah
yeah I think that like just simpler you
just learn things like in a different
way you know
also like I'm sure like you're in a
small town the two gay dudes people know
them right right so there's not like it
I think in the media when you see like
you know Republicans talk right and they
talk about you know that they don't
believe in you know gay rights or
whatever right that's just in the media
but I think in small towns they accept
them right a hundred percent like that's
the crazy thing like the only time
anybody ever put anybody on television
from my area was when like they needed
somebody seen an alien or something you
know yeah otherwise these people are
mostly doing good stuff you know yeah
it's just like they always go to like
one or two spots and pick out the worst
yeah right I think they'd do it for
almost everything you know but um you
never saw an alien growing up let me
thank you know one of my buddies died he
was on oxycontin and he choked to death
on a some type of a meat bone or
something I remember was chicken fowl my
beloved um I thought after he died that
he came to see me a couple times
loosened up so not alien that you're
talking about go tell ghost and you're
talking about the paranormal yeah
talking about not our interests real not
at rejoice yeah yeah you're talking
about go show yeah so you see when he
came back that he looked like an alien I
did he look like it was a or she was
outside
as himself I felt like it was him but he
seemed a little bit more you know kind
of Randi than he used to be a little
more active you know because you get a
little bit I bet you once you're dead
you're like oh I'm free you know that's
your Amistad man you're out of your body
you know you're about do you believe in
that in afterlife I do because we came
here like people was like you think you
go like a magical place in the sky you
know and everybody's just sitting around
and [ __ ] drinking rocket sauce and
doing magic you know yeah and I'm like
look where I'm at now bro I'm in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere on a ball the
[ __ ] dirt yeah it happened yeah this
the only proof I have so do I think
something like this could happen again
yeah I have to think that so when people
like you think you go to a crate a place
where this is a bunch of other people
that you don't know like if you're
talking about heaven you know and
everybody's doing good and I'm like yeah
we just like here but everybody would be
doing good you know yeah so I base it on
it's almost more like reincarnation a
little bit yeah I you know I don't
necessarily like geared towards always
believing in things that are factual in
order but Wow but two small common oh
but I do believe in like sort of like a
paranormal stuff because when you live
in a big city like this you're so all
your senses are drowned out constantly
by the noise of traffic by people around
you it's always chaotic but when I go
back to the provincial areas and the
Philippines who do sense something
different there you hear things more you
feel things more yeah and I always get
sort of a sense of like that paranormal
stuff when I'm back there but never here
in LA I can't even call it boredom it's
not boredom you think that's wrong
yeah you think goes come here here I
wake up no this is what happens
la I wake up a [ __ ] I gotta go here I go
to a Starbucks I go to the iPad store
get my sync screen fixed you me and I'm
gonna go see uh Joe some friend you
gonna [ __ ] babe store yeah right and
then you go to an a meeting that I got
two shows to do yeah you got [ __ ] to do
over there you wake up there's nothing
to do oh I see a ghost yeah I see it
here you see one time yeah it's like
thing like Oh what are we going to do
today I'm going to do it right Zach
there's nothing to do your mind and
right am I not right babe or no no oh
okay I just saw you kind of reinforce it
I was saying which is you don't allow
yourself to feel anything because you
pack your day with so much and your
feelings here it's hard to get your
feelings have no space here like I can't
even feel that much here
you know like I'm far more I noticed
once soon as I get outside of the city
limits I'm far more and you know I'm not
trying to be profane buddy erect yes I
guess you dig that feeling again yes my
life has feeling again like I don't see
how people have any feet there's no room
for your feelings here there's just no
you can't relax I can't anyway maybe if
you were brought up in this type of
environment yeah I'm like that in New
York really yeah if I'm working well
like when I wake up in a hotel room in
New York with all the noise and all that
stuff I could probably sleep for four
hours I got much walking around right I
just cannot sleep hmm it just is this
excitement in the air that [ __ ] to do I
don't know one time I was in [ __ ] New
York and I meet I don't know how I ran
into if I ran into Maz Jobrani hmm he's
like Indian or some [ __ ] what is this uh
Pakistani or whatever and he goes he
goes hey dude you want to go to a
Moroccan like nightclub but it's like
invite only and it's illegal I want to
go I want to go when those two things
Moroccan illegal I have to go okay all
right there's a 2002 elephant sorry I'm
there okay with the alleyway down these
steps through a red door we walk in and
then there's like a fire right and
there's people with bongo drums the two
you get right a tribal a guy is smoking
like see yes it's smoking things and
people are dancing right and I just
started dancing I start dancing too
because I didn't know what the [ __ ] to
do I'll scare ya right because mas
started to I think on med was there too
oh I meant right wait you gotta can't
yet you know is that I got right and
that's what to me New York is you know
so when I'm in LA I feel relaxed mm-hmm
right and if I go to like wherever
you're from I probably go into coma
yeah yeah I'll probably go into coma and
never
a couple gals got the idea public tones
that column ah sounds boring we didn't
have a lot of Asians man we had a there
was a rumor of an Asian when I was first
going to make I'm not sure it was a
rumor of a rumor was and I've talked
about this before I talked about this
before they had yeah they had a rumor
that there was an Asian kid right and
this is after because we got a Latino
kid
we got a Latina okay yeah yeah not a
family one kid when graduation one guy
one guy Nicholas was his name in a
little bit of like facial hair or less
everybody was fired up about that tired
it was a lot of rumors and stuff going
on about that yeah because yeah people
had never seen that on children
you know what real air other face yeah
like yeah or like he's trying to grow a
sideburn on his on his chin yeah so then
I was on the wrestling team in middle
school kind of fetus I had a fetus right
there because
Penasquitos was 60% Filipino their
wrestling team all the kids had
mustaches oh yeah all the Latinos have
mustaches by the time they're living I
mean literally we're female and male is
it like a handprint like a fingerprint
oh yeah we just grow mustaches like
nothing but we don't really grow the
rest though what we are like Manny
Pacquiao mustaches we all even the
female yeah yeah yeah but I remember
like wrestling against them with the
first time and they all have mustaches
right and we don't
oh yeah we're like we're kids you're
late bro yeah all right but our team was
so good yeah that we we beat them even
me I can't crush them yeah my brother
who never did
Marissa's that his name of Steve Steve
well there's only three that's Joe yes
Jesus correct the people who are
beautiful people most killed a Filipino
out there um but my brother had no
facial hair and here's this old man with
a mustache that he's fighting again so
wrestling in my eyes like I might put
the snapped him on the ground
we're like yell man you
man without a bow in 14 I know it was
amazing but anyway so anyway so the
fixable the rumor of the Asian though
you heard a rumor yeah that a rumor that
there was an asian boy in Slidell
Louisiana which was probably about 17
miles away and so we had to get over
there yeah you know we heard up and we
thought about it for a couple weeks and
then we started me on to my buddy's cut
grass man this kid Danny yeah who was a
good friend of mine and he had some he
had a couple different deficiencies but
he's doing okay now yeah you know and he
armed
we raised up some money saved up some
money over two months and then we called
a taxi over there yeah and we went to
this place where they're supposed to
have you know this asian boy [ __ ] I want
to say the name was Chet I'm trying to
take off the text I'm Michael Chang does
that sound checks hang to change yeah
yeah Chet [ __ ] right never found give us
you that's not enough it doesn't sound
next time it doesn't sound plausible
it doesn't sound plausible because I've
never been in Asia venom chat yeah there
are in Southeast Asia there you go
either I think it's either tie or wasn't
[ __ ] mate bruh check me the room so you
know we got there and he wasn't there it
was a wasn't there anyone here yes okay
the name is from the city city of
Chester England I know probably oh yeah
yeah and uh yeah we went there and I was
just like a laundromat somebody'd open
up like a new laundromat or like a
cleaning like a riot clothes there's no
was the Asian run laundromat I don't
know that could have been maybe somehow
that got diffused when it by the time I
got done well now I'm this way
pre-internet you know I write this
backlund what was the first do you
remember the first time you ever saw an
Asian in the flesh man I feel like it
was a man yeah I feel like it was a man
with glasses on you know but you did I
could probably draw a picture him but I
don't think that I could but I don't
think that I couldn't tell you when how
are you
after that I mean I guess I kind of gave
up on it after the yeah yeah after the
no-show check yeah but you would think
that you know go to real saving up money
to have to go see Chet you don't see
them that you would your gene to when
you're going to see another a right so
then when you see another asian at
airport or whatever you would go oh my
god and that would be in your thing but
that's fine yeah yeah i remember i went
to africa one time as i got a little bit
older and i was like holy [ __ ] you know
a lot of Africans are black you know
yeah yeah and I was like and that's when
I realized like heaven is mostly going
to be like black and Asian people you
know it's not going to be that many
white people there a lot of Indians
Chinese and black yeah yeah the tend to
be pack they're trying to have at 1
billion india has 1 billion and they're
done are they done pretty quick I mean
it's gonna be packed up there what do
you think I think you think about this
to think about this I thought about this
is that you don't hope you know when
like white people get pets yeah they do
funerals they go we'll see you in heaven
what I yeah you think that all the cats
are left and dogs that ever lived on
planet earth I'm going to be in heaven
too because if it is I don't want to be
there well imagine that just everything
that you can all the bees never existed
yeah all the allergies I mean it would
be yeah I have to open up a pharmacy up
there for people you can tell so you can
open a pharmacy in heaven right do
you're gonna ruin it yeah you can't be
this crazy guy who's bringing wood and
[ __ ] up sort of business people believe
people who do who believe in heaven
believe only humans get to go to heaven
or did we leave all living things go to
heaven what's a good question my belief
and I'm not sure exactly where how much
of religion was in ER just this idea
that I had was that it was me and
probably other people that I picked to
be there and like my loved ones you know
for some reason in my head I see what
relying everybody's there I think how
does this work if you see I think yo-yos
right yeah but you what if those loved
ones don't go to heaven if they don't go
to heaven and you just get like
memo or something are you here with the
halogen
how are you here that yeah like a verbal
memo yeah I got a writ one how is it
heaven for you then if you can't be with
that loved one who didn't make it to
heaven then you that's just the way it
kind of shakes out happens about 85% of
what you want right I don't count 100%
anymore yeah there's so many pennies to
be a hundred
I think there was a time when I saw me
on a percent well yeah yeah you know
everybody just made it up there
everybody in an Internet age right and
that market yeah and it's also how
Christians say they say no matter what
you've done on power how evil you are if
you accept Jesus Christ as your Lord and
Savior yeah that you will go to heaven
yeah so with that in mind you'll be up
there with some people that you know
don't necessarily want to be around
right some killers it took him in at the
last minute why right like you know
imagine being eaten by Jeffrey Dahmer
yeah he's right right the fridge of that
is fridge make it there and then she
before he died in prison he accepted
Jesus yeah and so now you're chilling on
a cloud with Cleopatra and the ones you
want to hang out with me thinking you
know no law you know gave her Dirty Jobs
yeah that guy yeah yeah and then all of
a sudden like row yeah jumping over
floats by on a cloud I mean how do you
feel hmm who are the people you want to
see most in heaven top 500 inside of my
family or in history in history like
it's like oh you know I know one Lou
Reed is one of yours well no I want to
change Lou Reed from the Baltimore
Ravens it was a singer yeah yeah Velvet
Underground a part of them yeah yeah I'm
trying to think I would probably go
Columbus probably why he was boring
Christopher Columbus in there okay man
yeah he was a shot you know anyway [ __ ]
you your anything about his personality
dude or what
it is aggressive but bros enemy right
all we know about this one right you're
driving with like I get on the boat I
think let's go west
Yeah right it's so you don't know what
he's going to be like in eternity you
don't know those little [ __ ] quirks
and whatnot no you don't know what he's
gonna be like all nobody's gonna be like
because he's in my [ __ ] top-five
Bobby
alright alright and I got ya because
here's the thing do to get onto a boat
that's the bravest thing and just go
somewhere you're not even knowing for
sure if like the world is round or flat
at that time well they did already know
and every morning you get up and you
have to like kind of make sure one of
your buddies doesn't have a disease for
you like get real close to him like
that's crazy bro turvy nothing kill you
dude yeah a cold will kill you you
couldn't make why not Magellan them bro
Oh Magellan would have been better but
he did kill a lot of people too and he
can lot of locals oh okay no yeah yeah
alright my people oh hang on so yeah I
like Columbus okay number two Columbus
number two maybe um probably one of the
kids from that movie um have you seen
the movie with Johnny Depp where he
plays Peter Pan yeah Finding Neverland
yeah yeah one of the kids from that
probably which kids you know the main
kid with the freckles like kind of a
necessary make their most troubled one
Buckingham who else
Christian Bale probably okay I don't
think I don't want straight up cooter on
this a yeah yeah yeah what do we get
probably ooh one of the chicks from
Friday Night Lights yeah are you will
Ali Landry mmm the tall blonde was the
one I love the one with a whipped cream
on her I don't know anything I'm talking
about the right movie the one I'm
talking about
yeah so one would not pose a wrong movie
I'll see sugar so so you never need a
mother figure we need somebody help take
care of everyone Judi Dench
name she's not dead yet Jesus she'll be
done when he's dead
she doesn't seem like she has any
nothing they'll get her breath yeah
that's pleasing I can help out
yeah somebody with some yeah Kathy Bates
Anna Nicole okay yeah they'd open she
got slim your 40-year old mill no okay I
don't know who's who of you the good
yogurt now it's like so Paul died when
she were real fertile and Anna Nicole
Smith yeah she seemed just like she just
be such a pain in the human energy old
boat rods gonna be about her I feel like
um yeah I don't good mother I don't know
Mom let me say something right now do I
ain't gonna visit you and have I'll tell
you that right now really [ __ ] your
[ __ ] people bro who's your people do
I have people too bro okay alright this
is an opportunity to tell them though
I'll tell you my people do I'll forget
Lou Reed babe okay like Irene Wow you
know what I want to go forward and if
you have to choose a woman unfortunately
and this doesn't
well yeah here's yeah here's the thing
though dude it's like in your thing
right you don't have so those are the
five celebrities or whatnot right you're
gonna have your mom and your dad and
everyone else right now yeah
so you get to pick five people aside
from your family yeah that you're just
an overall we wanted to meet in history
right the first is Gilbert Canady on the
list he doesn't have to be on my list
cuz I'm already gonna see him because my
friend yeah so five random people they
don't know you're in there like Kublai
Khan alright let me do mine alright whoa
what's so using I think I'm with radial
blur music I think I would do Pol Pot
why tell you why cuz Pol Pot dude he is
the scare man yeah yeah he's a heavy
hand he's not going to be in head the
Rottweiler why would you think Pol Pot's
would be in heaven except you don't know
this when he was in the village in
Thailand right if we accepted Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior
and he died in Thailand it eerily like a
DJ oh wow he's a rock well I'll tell you
right now Thailand harbored him oh
that's right I can live in a [ __ ]
village after he killed two million of
his own people
you know what Gilbert I love you so much
thanks man
and I find that you are irreplaceable
but if you did die how could I replace
you I have an idea what maybe there are
no idea zipper crew ah recruiter
yeah it says why is it or basically you
can find all the great candidates for
his job to replace Gilbert's so for
instance if we needed it to hire an
animator for our show to animate all 90
hours yeah
then we would go on zip recruiter and it
posts to all to over like a hundred
different job websites and it finds the
right candidates for us right that's
basically a one-stop shop for all you
know everything that you need to find
the proper candidate for here job that's
really really convenient by now today
why is it recruiter has been used by
businesses of all sizes to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now you guys can post
jobs with different career for free
that's right a free go to zip recruiter
dot-com slash belly that zip recruiter
slash home slash belly one more time to
try it for free go to zip recruiter comm
slash belly yeah yeah and when people
from other countries see you in their
country do they feel like they want you
to rescue them race like that like was
there any stuff like that like take me
with you Bobby or take Lola in the
Philippines yeah remember the [ __ ]
hotel guy what happens Amin innocently
the builders and I use a console you
have a job for me in America
oh yeah go what yeah I work very hard
you know I go yeah okay here's my number
did he call you no oh
hi bro did you would you give every
number yes I would yeah I mean no ever
they're all like that Wow yeah Filipino
people happiest people I've ever met
them yeah if you have them in Louisiana
now I did some military tour on this
base one time and they had oh just a lot
of uh Pinos whether they call them
pinoys and now it always yeah you know
yeah Filipino Grigio that was my wine
that I came out with a long time but uh
but they had a lot of Pinos out there
and they were good just cool guy
you know happy all the same like a kind
of like a medium shirt t-shirt all like
the exact same kind of chest in arms
just have you ever penetrated a asian
lady before I remember made love pretty
badly I'm not really good at sex to a
yawl Korean girl in Idaho why Korean
Korean and it was awkward I don't know
how much cream was in there but it was
enough and you noticed it yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I remember her leg she had like
legs that were very you know just dirty
yes dirty yeah guru Korea that's Korea
you couldn't get them apart it was a
different way chopsticks that like her
so it is really strong yeah and except
for own a bit yes yeah yeah I'm just
saying that your doctor related to it
like you know you ever get those chops
in here like oh I can't separate them
you know not her like that was like that
man yeah varies a dick stocky legs bro
yeah right did you eventually break the
chops down I mean it didn't even matter
I mean I am bad at sex so it's like you
get a little bit of sex and you know and
it's are you really bad or just saying
that because you're comedian no I'm
pretty bad at it no I was good when I
was young when I was young dude [ __ ]
yeah you know but yeah but now I
probably chat with you yeah possibly we
do like some mutual masturbation maybe
some sex
we mutual masturbation is the best yeah
very possible at a certain point it is
yeah and some of it I think is just kind
of evolving you know it's like some of
them like if you're still [ __ ]
somebody you're sometimes like just a
weirdo I think right yeah sometimes but
then sometimes you got to let the beast
out of your heart you know and I
sometimes you know I just I don't know
man it's call it's just so there's so
many feeling sometimes going on inside
of you when you're trying to deal with
like love and sex but I'll tell you what
I'd revert you know then why know is
because the fact that you you got sober
yeah and how much Saban do you have now
let me see 11 a little over 11 months
yes and when that happened yes your mind
clears yeah and new emotions around
the if things won't have to deal with
life on life terms yeah and this is what
you're dealing with what do you feel
more in your dick since you've been so
fair I feel a little more out of my dick
kind of out of your day really yeah Odie
Odie because I feel like drunk sex I
never really feel I can't even like
climb nothing there's chunks pecs is
just fun the idea is fun right
during but you never remember the actual
pleasure from being drunk and having sex
you tell in your clothes that's what I
like really yeah the crime the idea is
enticing but the actual fact the actual
part of doing it drunk is only fun at
the time that you're drunk that's the
only time even remembering it's me and
fist-fighting and [ __ ] I remember was
more fun when you were drunk you know
yeah like this okay yeah we're just
clear so what what is that I would
actually teach a no though in your life
in you know I think I just yeah I mean
I'd you know it's a good point you bring
up because I feel like I do have more
feelings now you know and I feel like
you're clearer to be honest with you
definitely yeah go to your face yeah
it's just like a performer like just the
complexion is a little healthier yeah
and you seem health just to help you in
general
oh yeah appreciate that man and I know
that you're taking it seriously because
you know I'm sober too and I I get this
observing you farm and I know that
you're active and you're doing it you
know and that's that's great yeah man I
appreciate that dude it's good and I
mean the interesting thing is how many
how many other people you meet we're
doing it and it's just that's the kind
of thing it keeps you going a lot of
times you'll just feel like ah and then
somebody else will tell you a story or
you meet somebody else's in the program
it's just like okay yeah you know there
is something going on here something
magical kind of yeah a lot more people
in the boat than you thought initially
because I mean even since I've met him I
realized it's like so many people are
actually sober and who are fully
creative people and who are just as wild
as Lobby like when people see him the
perception is always oh he's either high
or you know yeah
like an entirety something that we got
released from another country deal would
you would you look at me though wouldn't
it be a great movie it's like we get
back one of ours from Bobby's country
they also have to sit Bobby's like eow
but we also like we got to get rid of
eyes yeah yeah
would you mean you think I'm a disaster
I'm a disaster oh I know what do I think
when I see you like I want you think mom
I think I see like a kind of like a
cocaine cartoon that kind of jumped off
the page and it's been running from his
drawer you know yeah oh I got a lot I
feel like he's on the run from your
artist all right and you're just doing
whatever you can and just stay on the
lam you know you're hanging out here
with this guy in the closet and big
fighting Here I am ginger ginger root
right here and I know yeah Emmys Michael
Landon over here Michael well except but
ya mean I don't know you're the only
committee that makes me laugh just by
seeing you see have a special gift I
think it's a nice if you have but it's
not a lot of it because people I hate
when people do that like Erik Griffin
said that then I'm at diddy you know if
you just walk around and you're just
like this I'm mad but he's probably
jealous of it though look at his Bono
oh yeah definitely we talked about of
every podcast but I think you're a
special guy man I think you always
surprising that there's other layers to
you which is it oh man I was like or to
get a note I'm surprising is that I've
been looking underneath the table and
you guys have been playing footsie for
about an hour yeah I love the oh man
well it makes me feel nice I'll say
these are always very accepting of other
people and so that's a nice because
especially as comedians it's tough
sometimes to you know you want you don't
want to impose and convenient I've been
doing it longer so when other comedians
are nice to you that have been doing it
longer it's really makes you feel help
being a more confident yeah we know it's
another yeah I would always think
sellout I saw David Spade might he came
up he always makes fun like he says
jokes like because where'd you park a
rickshaw right and I laugh whatever
right I'm stupid but here is I you know
he always taxes me as self I'm just a
really nice guy why and I just thought
because he's been he's ahead of me when
I
and it makes me feel like oh this guy's
really cool he is a really nice cool guy
you know and I just feel like when I
started I didn't run into those guys
yeah
when I started I ran into a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] I thought wow now and
um I just like support and I like
supporting Calzaghe I really believe
when I watch you perform even the [ __ ]
that you were saying here in this
podcast it's the same vein of like you
is this guy real Yeah right
because it seems real he with his
descriptions he paints a world where he
comes from I don't know if it's if I go
to that world for real that it would be
like exactly the way he describes it but
still it's very vivid in my mind I
really I've told him a million times you
gotta create a show about your life
about your where you come from
yeah in Louisiana all those guys with
the deficiencies and Chad yeah yeah like
an episode of you looking for 17 you
know 70 miles away there's a Chinese guy
we gotta save our money yeah there's one
episode it's very funny yeah right
thanks man and it's not rooted in racism
it's just ignorant white people what are
they ignorant well well me well meetings
our hearts are pure she's private this
is dumb you know man
and here's another thing that I've said
to you before and I know that you're
gonna hate me bring it up and I don't
know why you're ashamed of it is that
thing we talked about in the elevator
what reality television yeah yeah I'm
not ashamed of and I was so I started
out in reality TV I was a road rules
cast right in 1999 and they don't have
to show anymore oh it's darkness no you
remember it I agree I grew up watching
you a little early yeah talk from
America man we're all bro but I grew up
in bro put a flag patch on
I grew up in LA bro you know I grew up
in Georgia and I used to write all the
time awesome man
yeah good um yeah I mean it was just a
wild time I guess it's just because it's
hard to like it's not hard to separate
from it it's just like it was just I was
so young you know I'm 37 now like I was
19 oh my god
that doesn't count it just doesn't it
does it and also I'm going to say this
yeah is is that if because I don't I
don't never seen the show I part of it I
don't know that you're from there yeah
and a lot I think a lot of comics are
like that a lot of Cubs that are older
or like you know what the [ __ ] is that
we don't be part of it but you know you
your merit it's what you are now that I
judge you by yeah okay and what I see is
a comic a real comedian with real chops
who's in a ghost places yeah and for you
to get spots at the store The Improv
Laugh Factory on nightly basis which is
what you do yeah to do headline I know
what rooms you play yeah they're all all
a list rooms yeah that's not you know a
reality show guy that's a real comics
right you know life yeah so it's like
it's something that you did in the past
but I think it's interesting to do a
show like that show what's called a rule
road rules and to reinvent yourself
that's right Jamie Chung I know you went
to interact yeah yeah maybe Chandra she
was on the real world yeah they know
Kristina provin ski what does she do
cause if he was a rogue age cast right
she is hilarious yeah yeah hilarious
okay you know in certain instances you
can come from a show like that yeah what
I swear to [ __ ] god when I left MADtv
I couldn't get auditions because
Catherine's directors would be like yeah
he's from that TV yeah it was a negative
thing mmm right so I just went oh it's
gonna go back to stand out they don't
want me mmm and then you see key and
Peele Jordan you know Keegan I come
punch of people do well I'm doing okay
yeah
and now those things are not said
anymore it's more of a thing
they're from that right right but for
many years I was ashamed of it I really
wanted it was like a shameful thing
really oh yeah because nobody wanted
like it there was a sense of like that
it wasn't cool right right and and it
wasn't I don't think at the time but if
you look at who's come from there the
lineage the comedy lineage I mean the
people even writing like oh yeah yeah I
mean Colton Dunn who's on superstore
superstore but he was one of our liners
yeah Mears Michael Hitchcock from all
the Christopher Guest movies was one of
our producers I mean there's a Lana when
we would go to MADtv would hang out with
Eugene Levy and all these guys are you
singing out there John Candy's daughter
I mean all the SAT be the history of it
would be there but we in terms of the
media or in general the country we don't
give a [ __ ] right but I can't change my
past and when they offer me the show I
took it yeah because what am I also
gonna do yeah opportunity yeah and I get
it and I'm fine
my career is fine my point though is is
that you came from there but it's
nothing to be ashamed of yeah and I
remember like you know I used to bring
you up like that you didn't like it I
won't I understand why then yeah because
you want the audience you know mean but
I just think that you should never run
from it did yes people land we don't
respect it I get what you're saying
because we're stigma attached to reality
TV in general and the types of
characters that are in reality TV today
which you know you know it you do it's a
stigma yeah so I take forever on it is
when you don't have talent yeah you're
right yeah you know we do you know when
PC a lot of these guys it's a lottery
they won a lottery ticket but then some
people actually have talent yeah real
talent and at 19 if they were to ask me
to do road rules it would have changed
my life
yeah I got no [ __ ] ID no friends
nothing at 19 I was invisible
were you really ready oh absolutely I
walk into anywhere and no one saw me
yeah all right and so
of course I would have taken that at 19
yeah I mean I had no plans of going to
comedy or being a comedian I didn't have
any I was just walking across campus at
college and I was just like really
really depressed and they had like
auditions and then next thing you know I
was uh they called me one day and they
asked me to to go on this trip you know
and I was like oh this is going to be
really really interesting and then yeah
and then that's how I got into it I
think the part that kind of burned me
was like or the part that got to me was
like whenever I got out to LA years
later and I decided I'm gonna get in I
want to do stand-up some of it was there
was times where you know I liked making
people laugh because I always you know
like and this is part of alcoholism you
just I just never felt I always thought
people just didn't like me ever since I
was young and just some of those wrong
with me I had this ism where I thought
people just didn't like me and it just
there was nothing I could ever do in a
moment to feel any different and so I
knew if I was making people laugh that
they had to be liking me for that few
seconds because they couldn't hate you
can't not like somebody in laugh right
so it was like a real proof that I had
you know visually and so you know then I
got into making people laugh and and
then you would get out to like places
and then there was always just like
these dudes who would like come from
other cities or whatever who'd probably
auditioned to be on these reality shows
it was like it was always those types of
people I would see when I go into
auditions and stuff who would always
kind of I guess made me feel negative
about it right right you know so I don't
know if sometimes the the feelings came
from me as much as they did probably
just from some weird lack of acceptance
so yeah and back in Louisiana people
would like try to fight me at bars and
guys would like I remember people
throwing bottles at me and like it just
got crazy and that's one of the reasons
why I left Louisiana was because it got
so crazy yeah you know it just got out
of jealousy right probably I guess I get
draw the [ __ ] this guy you know he's on
TV and TV and again where they call me
the n-word to what am I
like I mean I'm told us Nicaragua yeah
yeah
so yeah just idiot you know I mean
there's a lot of idiocy in a lot of
places so but that made me feel on that
is the suffering yeah you coming to LA
and you know what to be honest it
probably wasn't good for you in the
beginning when you came to LA yeah right
those things could have been real that
now they were like saying Shannon
whatever right but the thing is is that
the suffering is key it motivates you
right to go I'm gonna get through this
yeah without suffering there is no
reward or true reward that's I believe
that yeah all those moments of me going
oh my god I'm out
I will show none I will show you yeah
one day I will show you and that idea
that feeling I still have it'll never go
away yeah that I am going to show you
what I'm capable of yeah I think some of
that hit me man why I got into me I was
like okay like you know I didn't even
have a chance I was making really any
choices in my life I was 19 and then now
you guys are going to say of this guy
isn't you know talented or this guy
couldn't be an entertainer you know or
and I was like okay I'm gonna take the
hardest job to do I'm gonna take
stand-up and I'm gonna do that
yeah because then there's no way that
anybody could say they can say whatever
they want but with stand-up there's no
nobody can help you they can get you up
on the stage but you got to have to be
up there on like that you know we have
to do that right you are now following
because the summer spots that you get
are later
right I mean you I've seen the lineups
where it's like heavy [ __ ] hitters
dude oh yeah and you go up there and
crush - oh yeah that's like a rodeo
right one saying is that that right
there should show people a lot yeah
which is like that's a legitimate
soldier [ __ ] but I think you're also a
point in your career where I don't think
anyone doubts that any more like right
oh yeah you have a seat you know you've
been around long enough as a stand-up
that I don't think anyone would ever
question that about you at least for me
like I didn't know you from really rules
and yeah I saw you like
there was no doubt in my mind that your
legitimacy is 150% like I never thought
I wonder where this guy came from where
he started it was like no this guy's
been doing stand-up all his life that's
what I thought right yo do you would be
I'm gonna be real with you right now do
I promise you this man I promise you
this right now man okay I never bring it
up again but I just needed a video this
one baby shouldn't have brought it up I
know I brought up this one time just to
address it yeah but you and I were past
it okay
I mean all right will you speak up you
and I are past it okay and we're going
to move beyond April okay okay all right
I have no I don't know what I said you
got to do this no no no baby that's it's
no yes Ambrose no no no she thinks that
this when I do this right you've been
negative it is negative or not it is it
is it's negative it's positive you might
go right carry on I got all dark it's
not a gun you know it because you know
what you don't see huh oh I can say
right now pipeline thoughts touching me
right now there he is where you don't
see it but right okay yeah okay well we
are but now I feel you bro I mean look I
feel you man you know a prime you know I
mean I appreciate your thoughts on it
there moment have that you know I don't
have that my bad I don't I mean I don't
ever think about it that much anymore
except for yeah no I mean I mean I'm
it's interesting to talk about the crazy
thing is generally I wish I had a ton of
like memories and stuff I was just so
young and I was just so you're partying
to Bobby's party I'm just like college
19 honestly how much man Lucy did you
get I mean I feel like I probably you
know didn't please a lot of women yeah
yeah but was really hot back then I mean
they had they had they had [ __ ] back
then imagine because man imagine being
19 you're good-looking dude right I'm
like an 8 as long as I brush my teeth
I'm an eight yeah yeah yeah good look at
you you're 19 I look kinda like to do
not realize that I look like to do that
always
people always accuse a farting I feel
- probably hardest anyone a funny
probably you know then riled actually
funny right and that's how we got the
[ __ ] Road rules at college woody how
many people audition for that ten
thousand people know like fifty thousand
every year yeah it's crazy right yeah so
yeah so that he beat all those people
and whatnot you know man and then they
all move to Los Angeles and became
casting directors executives and then
got angry at me whenever I walked into
that we do now though see it was now we
go over to UM Gilbert and we do a
question from the internet and we
Gilbert honestly is uh is uh it was a
popular name on the Little House on the
Prairie do you remember that you watch
that and so it is I didn't know there
was a name did they get that where where
is he from again yeah yeah from Atlanta
you got to get onto yeah don't eat good
show it's not a - oh well sorry yeah it
is and that would be my fifth actually
Michael Lando Vila yeah it's not why is
that a good show he said Michael
Anderson yeah Tina Rob the Boston well I
want to talk about Little House on the
Prairie real quick okay I think that
he's crossed the line with me really
yeah look you can't my table I don't
know why I got out of it I am drawing
the line at [ __ ] Little House on the
Prairie Jenna page [ __ ] what worked
all summer to go see you when I was a
kid and you weren't there dude where
leaners check the river a VA revealed
and I think yeah you bro yeah I opened
up store for two months yeah and I do
feel those colors I closed it down dude
we could go on tour right now and you
could be the first Asian that a ton of
people have ever met how great with that
I know they know be real wages come your
show be real right now but I'm just
saying what town are you from loop from
one coming in Louisiana Huffington yeah
let me tell you something right now Lee
Harvey Oswald with our middle school Wow
thank you incoming incoming t'n
right call being done come on right over
oh damn dude
selling sword broke Bobby look like even
telling sower [ __ ] up in covington yeah
better than in Kennington yes there are
no asians in Cummington
I don't think there are any more I mean
they might have had one you know at a
certain point or a couple of it came
through in some sort of program but I
don't think that you're not if you ask
somebody like where can beats amazing
people here nobody's gonna know a lot of
Vietnamese there huh Vietnamese Viet
it'll be at them and I know let me ask
you tonight I love the vs man ups and
all summer I run the Vietnamese and I
love the Vietnamese I've been to Vietnam
I've been in LA Saigon Shang pen yeah I
mean I actually I mean I mean I'm a big
fan of short pants with rice yeah dude
and I get you murdered so he asked her
questions from the internet what the
call it's called unhelpful advice he is
gonna do it in the new week we answer
okay great but I will tell you that I
could take you to places towns right now
we would show up and it would be like
come meet the first Asian you've ever
met and you would be that first you
[ __ ] weirdo we got any after you have
to go we have to do it let me do that I
have to film it
oh dude I could take you to at least
what am I gonna die no they're gonna
love it
how it's gonna come in and see the Asian
girl is traveling a freak show like I
like I'm the hairy face boy yeah what no
we had a hairy face boy at our town just
kid named thunder kay yeah and he go
yellow
yeah the disease the hairy faces no he
had long hairy face disease Jerry Lee
says cornrow his cheek love the black
girl with cornrow his cheeks in the
summer give him a little bit of relief
from the heat but um but yeah I could
take you to towns right now and I could
meet seven and eight and nine year olds
that have never met an Asian oh I see
okay well let's do that one hair I think
we should you guys have long I mean it
would be really fascinating don't you
Tony I think it'd be fine I'm very fine
so you'll put a tent up and sort of
cannot and we'll go Asian guy and then a
local area but you
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba watch whatever using
closed area where they couldn't touch me
or now it should be a staircase up to
like a like a tent or something yeah
yeah yeah let's do that let's do that
cool see that yeah yeah my first Asian
you know yeah with Bobby on hope of us
with Bobby
kilala and Silva presents my first Asian
coming to Louisiana Wow bro well that's
cool town that is uh hello my name is
Katherine I'm a seventeen year old and
I'm currently worried about my social
life after middle school my personality
flipped on me and now I'm a shy
introvert that can't seem to connect
with people every time I push myself to
talk to someone I find them boring and I
give up on them people seem to be a hit
or miss with me and currently everyone
at school has seemed to be a hit or miss
for me as well how should I go about -
fixing my social life Catherine 17 years
old I'd say go do some help somebody
else it sounds like you're just a little
bit caught up in your own ego I think
Catherine another some tough to tell a
17 year old but you know you just I
don't know you're thinking about a lot
from you like you this way and you that
way and you know I put the phone down in
just repeat go go help some people go
help somebody that's crippled or
somebody that you know that might have a
gay lover on a small baby seat yeah yeah
somewhat ISM also is being 17 right man
yeah but 17 bro what do you mean 17 I
was Moody bro you're introverted moody a
clich s I did all kinds of [ __ ] bro did
you really yeah do you don't seem like
that can I go well I lost my stepdad bro
I was Coco actually was Coco Joey Gino
yeah yeah answer enter it huh yeah yeah
yeah close enough Coco yo Joey it's
Bobby Lee dude we were he's on my
podcast right now bro
I'm just videos doing my podcast right
now oh [ __ ] what's going on and now
you're we're looking beautiful you're a
guest star right now what's happening
gentlemen so we just don't pleasure
beyond Dino Lodge podcast oh no the old
school cat I
raise your brother bobby ring yeah but
Joey will you do my podcast what are you
gonna do my podcast yeah you're doing it
tonight
you're gonna be in soon okay bro I'm
gonna call you I love you buddy all
right all right all right you too Joe
thanks for checking it oh he's a best
man you will call me like once every
couple weeks let's check and see how I'm
doing you're gonna make me cry
yeah why I don't know yes nice guy like
you said man it's like you know people
doing those nice things man it reminds
me sometimes if I was shown as young
dude on and I'll hit him up and be like
you were hilarious or something you know
yeah or just something that's going to
boost his spirits yeah but yeah I don't
know maybe I'm being a little bit rude
to the 17 year old you know I just
that's actually good advice to every
single teenager and I wish someone had
said that to me when I was 17 because I
really was a little bit too full of
myself not even in the sense that I was
actually full of myself I was just
thinking of myself and everything
everything that pertained only to me how
the world exists and how it pertains to
me only not the other way around and
that's yeah I didn't service me later
and I got stuck in that so yeah it's a
tough thing to get stuck in I was lost
man were you yeah we a lot I got sober
when I was 17 Oh God bro my first time
so sober was 17 dude I stayed sober
until I was 30 but dude I was lost and
when you went out of 30 how long do you
go out there for couple years man
painful damn real painful I Joey Diaz
almost killed a couple times I used to
like I used to bring [ __ ] a [ __ ]
suitcase full of pills
Oh Joey Diaz was the first one I was
handed to yeah yeah and then he would
like take like my pills and then like he
would take a pillow and then go to the
bathtub and then lay the you know pillow
in the bathtub
put the shower on take my pills and just
fall asleep cause I thought he was gonna
die yeah you know that's Vietnam right
there he is maybe you're making your own
beer bro with all that moisture so
what's your name man Oh Catherine
Catherine that's good luck
load love gathering 17 supposed to be
really confusing so you're right on bond
you're right on target to say that I had
to cancel on your show in North Carolina
North Carolina this weekend I'm so
[ __ ] sorry I'll tell you what
happened I have to shoot love mm-hmm and
it conflicted and I feel really bad
about it because I really wanted to go I
love North Carolina is it Charlie I love
Charlotte and I really do i comedy so I
like that room a lot yeah I apologize
and I hope that you guys will forgive me
and that I can come back one day hmm you
have anything to plug feel yeah man I'll
plug um I got my album it's called
thirty pound bag of hamster bones it's a
good one because I used to sell hamsters
rolling up I was amazing I was in the
hamstring getting guinea pig game for a
bit and what else I'll be in New York
City this weekend we planned I'm playing
at Gotham June 23rd and 24th great room
and then I will be in Nashville and that
is uh July 7th full room at lap eight as
Amy's I love that room and I haven't
been so I'd love the support people come
out it's good room dude I'm excited
Andrew and those guys they're the great
dudes man it's a great room yeah Mick
said radio rbq you can have a good time
oh really yeah yeah you like barbecue
bro mmm yeah I do like it never had
Korean barbecue oh we have you've never
had real barbecue no but I'll tell you
this so one time they had a pet I don't
pose a pet shop or what it was in
Vietnam right and they they were killing
animals they were killing animals it
could have been like a butcher - yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah yeah not what Korean
Bobby head of it
well they had a dove dude that I'm like
this is a peace bird you know and I
think yeah yeah yeah yeah I've actually
eaten dove before a couple of brothers
used to cook dove up by me when I was
growing up idea and I see a meetin dove
and for years I'm like I don't need
peace meat restaurant and then finally I
had some yeah but uh gaming you can't
get the fact that you're eating peace
out of your head
for me but anyhow how many a hippie yeah
it's like yeah it's like eating
something you know it's like eating a
dick that's just given up for [ __ ]
and it's just going to try to help
people and no it's not like that
yeah it's not exactly that exact like as
bad as it was a really bad idea but
anyway uh they were I bought it I bought
this bird right I bought a bird I'm like
I'm gonna give his verdict freedom you
know right I'm gonna get out here and
just Andy Dufresne this little girl
right so I bought this dove off this
butchery at this butcher yeah and I got
it I throw it up in the air like that to
let it go
immediately like seven Vietnamese people
came by with nets if I caught it oh I'm
not even joking I snapped its neck
immediately oh [ __ ] and left on to
wherever they win it yeah well you know
who Keyser söze is from Kill Bill
Whitner often yes or no was it no do
Keyser söze is no let's move on do you
know
Elon Musk is yeah oh yeah she was a
buddy of mine some spaghetti with him
whatever goes with over his house all
the time
he said that Elon gave him the spaghetti
like this he goes you want some
spaghetti he's like sure instead of
fixing him as own dish yeah he just puts
him out of his dish on a fork and put it
about what itself ah who's your buddy
this young guy homosexual gentleman is a
Manticore Weiss beautiful guy and
beautiful fancy guy just gotta give
Giovanni round of applause oh but that
was wonderful
oh that was wonderful thank you anything
handles for social media just at the ov
on th EO vo n and yeah just check out my
tour dates I'm coming up in some neat
spots and I really appreciate you having
me Bobby I'm a big fan I love you man
love you too
that was great it was so [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] guys make sure you follow us on
instagram at tiger belly and on twitter
at that Tiger billet you can email us
any questions or unhelpful advice at the
Tiger belly at gmail.com and make sure
you guys that you check out our survey
and helpless figure out what our
demographics are by going to survey
Lipson calm slash tiger belly
yeah yeah what is this joint man if
you're hiring don't forget to go to zero
Krueger comm / belly guys that's a good
day nice
[Music]